denn deutschland befindet sich offiziell
bis zum 10 januar 2021 im lockdown aber
ist das wirklich das ende dafür ist
jetzt bei uns unser bild politik chef
jan schäfer den jan du hast nachrichten
ja es gab heute eine sehr interessante
schaltkonferenz des chefs des
bundeskanzleramtes helge braun mit den
chefs der staatskanzleien der 16
bundesländer wurde dann darüber
gesprochen wie soll es nächste woche
denn weitergehen am dienstag ist ja der
große gipfel der bundeskanzlerin mit den
16 ministerpräsidenten und aus dieser
schalter haben wir erfahren dass man
sich einig ist diesen locker und dem wir
bisher haben zu verlängern
eventuell um zwei wochen vielleicht
sogar um drei wochen das heißt bis zum
24 januar oder sogar bis zum 31 januar
was bedeuten würde dass auch die
geschäfte beispielsweise weiterhin
geschlossen haben friseursalons theater
kinos also alles das was jetzt
eigentlich zu es und geschlossen hat
auch bis zum mindestens 24 januar er
sogar bis zum 31 januar geschlossen
haben wird sie haben gleich noch eine
art schutzwall hältst du es für möglich
wenn die zahlen bleiben wie sie sind
dass wir dann noch mal verlängern und
noch weitere blöcke bleiben also das was
man hört auch vom chef des
bundeskanzleramtes von helge braun
deutet alles darauf hin dass wir auch im
februar und möglicherweise sogar noch
bis in den märz hinein mit einem locker
und rechnen müssen wie hat er dann ist
das ist eine frage die sicherlich dann
auf einer nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin geklärt wird also nach
dem 10
januar aber alles was wir so bisher
höheren riecht eigentlich danach dass
wir uns darauf einstellen müssen dass es
bis märz noch sehr sehr ungemütlich
werden kann
keine einfachen zeiten vielen dank für
diese schnell nachrichten du bist später
noch einmal bei uns dankeschön
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren